hey what's up guys mkbhd here and as you
probably already know there was an apple
event today and i did some tweeting
throughout the entire event giving my
impressions of what was announced this
isn't a full recap video i'll leave the
best ones that i can find uh down right
below the like button on this video in
the description so you can click to
check those out i'm sure you know where
to find them people like tld today
soldier knows best etc but i just want
to give a quick thought about something
that actually struck me today that
wouldn't have to do with the whole
entire thing so apple went through their
whole lineup as they usually do they
introduced the new ipad 4 the ipad mini
the 13 inch macbook pro the new imac and
the new mac mini and then i was actually
struck by the fact that apple's desktops
still have this sort of a
form factor going on that confuses me
but gives me hope for the future so
basically apple's desktop lineup right
now is the mac mini the imac and the mac
pro we'll start with the mac mini the
mac mini as you guys probably already
know is not totally user serviceable i
did the fastest mac mini in the world
series where i did some user upgrades
that aren't necessarily endorsed by
apple by putting an ssd in it on my own
but basically the only thing that they
want you to get at is the ram and it's
otherwise basically a macbook pro in a
desktop body it has the same motherboard
a mobile motherboard it has a mobile
graphics card and it has a mobile cpu
and all the components basically fit the
same way a macbook pro does except it's
in the body of a desktop and they call
it the mac mini since it doesn't have to
have a display it ends up costing less
than the macbook pro and there you have
the cheapest mac you can get so that's a
pretty good bargain and then there's the
imac with the new imac there's a 21.5
inch and a 27 inch imac and they're both
really really thin and this again brings
the notion of a glorified macbook pro it
is very similar to a laptop in a desktop
chassis not necessarily a bad thing this
is easily the most efficient desktop you
can get but it's still not very user
upgradable this new imac is absurdly
thin it is beautiful by all accounts no
one can disagree with that but it's uh
it's so thin that the only thing you can
upgrade still in the 27 inch only is the
ram in fact you need to take apart the
21.5 inch imac just to upgrade the ram
so i can't really qualify these as true
thoroughbred desktops so that leaves the
mac pro as the only true apple desktop
right now and i can explain basically
it's the only one that has a desktop
motherboard desktop chip desktop cpu
desktop graphics card and desktop
available upgraded components which
means i can go in and swap out the ram i
can go in and change out the graphics
card at any time because of the way is
designed now the mac pro that's
currently being sold by apple is
currently rocking a graphics card from
route 2010 and a slightly outdated intel
cpu so that gives me a lot of hope for
the next version of the mac pro which
could be huge apple could do two things
with the mac pro next year in 2013. they
could one kill it off but i don't want
them to do that or they could do two and
totally revamp it just like they did
with the new imac and keep the full true
desktop form factor with upgradable
components a neat idea they could do at
least my idea would be having a
mid-range tower in the same form factor
as a regular mac pro and a super
high-end tower so you could have the
mid-range tower be a little bit smaller
have user upgradeable components new
ivory bridge processor new high-end
graphics cards and very very easy easy
to use design you can swap in ssds and
hard drives and everything like that and
that could start at a price somewhere
around eighteen hundred dollars and then
you could keep of course your pro name
because the pros that are you know doing
video editing in hollywood and doing
after effects and all kinds of crazy
things really need the high-end specs
you could sell a high-end version of the
new mac pro and it would retail probably
closer to the 2400 that you guys are
starting it out right now so that's my
idea for the new imac i can give a
thumbs up if you agree i said imac i
meant mac pro
but that's the kind of idea i had for
what they could do with the mac pro in
2013. other than that apple did a great
job today they introduced a lot of great
new products that i'm sure a lot of you
guys will be picking up let me know what
was your favorite thing that was
introduced today at the keynote my
personal favorite was probably the new
imac it looks pretty awesome again i
won't be getting one because it's not
quite a true desktop
but uh i have a macro down here and i'll
be waiting for the next mac pro
hopefully apple gets on that get on that
apple either way thanks for watching
guys just a quick overview video you
guys can see all the stuff that apple
announced in the link below which will
probably be someone's update video about
everything that happened and i'll talk
to you guys in the very next video i'm
off to new york to take a look at the
united states version of the galaxy note
2. see you guys later
peace
you